order
well I'm the Nostalgia good guy remember
it so you don't have to hey kids you
like cat videos you know my dog videos
you want to see a movie bottle well too
bad that's what we got inert
ever see that movie that looks really
stupid then are shocked when it turns
out to be a surprisingly good film well
this is one of those bad looking films
you think might be a surprisingly good
film resulting in a surprisingly bad but
the idea for this is right out of a
Warner Brothers cartoon they can be
pretty funny and imaginative but instead
you're left wondering which category to
put it in kitty litter or pooper scooper
so let's find out the truth about cats
and dogs one of you must be a genie
Gruffalo rom-com fan Tommy I'm not a lot
this is cats and dogs it opens with the
world's fastest sunrise where we see a
cat and dog pretty much as being a cat
and dog till it turns into a really bad
Doritos commercial fun fact this was
actually supposed to be a crossover
between crappy CGI Garfield and crappy
CGI Marmaduke until they realized no we
cut to a woman setting a pie on the
windowsill in her 50 style dress with a
bow inner abran because somebody
somewhere thinks somebody somewhere
still does that when the cat and dog
land on now her reaction to the can't
landing on her is fine but look at her
face when the dog lands on her
al Qaeda faces that comedic expressions
are supposed to get big or as more stuff
happens not scaled down how do you even
duplicate that face what direction do
you give to get a face like that alright
I want you to act like you just
discovered you lost your firstborn child
but you found out while shopping the
world's greatest vibrator in you
specific but confusing you're presumably
suffering third-degree burns the dog
comes across what he thinks is the ran
over cat it's a trick get an axe but a
man of cats comes by to abduct him and
if you're thinking to yourself okay that
was a tolerable short film I'm sad to
say that movie comes with it
control here we've got a serious problem
shouldn't that be dognapped if you're
kidnapped you're not held hostage by a
kid unless it's this kid but I'm never
taking that babysitting job again we
then cut to a farm where a new litter of
puppies are waiting in a barn just guess
which one of them is the dreamer and
when I say dreamer I'm using the movie's
definition meaning never happy wherever
the hell you are I want adventure
not wait for someone to take me to some
boring old house don't you want to do
something exciting like be a police dog
what about one of those Russian space
dogs are maybe sample the great bones of
Europe
you know as dogs we're not so easily
entertained why did I yearn for never
being satisfied
that's Tobey Maguire by the way is Lou
the main character and as much as I love
to imagine Maguire in pain I have to
admit it's not much fun watching a dog
it's seriously injured
I know it's affecting everything but how
much fun is it really to constantly see
cute little doggies get pummeled into
hard solid walls isn't that like what
sick kids watch is that a dog's head
being smashed into away huh is that
another dog falling is that just missing
yes miss yes what is wrong with you it's
okay it's funny because that's cartoon
sound effects I'm telling mommy gal that
you're watching this alright kids time
to watch cats and dogs it's rated PG so
we just had to tell you not to say the
ones where were that they use in the
movie
it's funny because it has heart too and
some people might be honey what's for
dinner
you guys like hot dogs right Wow so the
puppies are being sold off but it looks
like they're replaced by other dogs from
a secret organization top-secret
operation
into the hole oh by the way you never
see those puppies again they vanished
from the rest of the movie what are we
supposed to assume they did with them
alright puppies into the room edge of
the room gotta work so one of the
replacement dogs is supposed to be
adopted but Lewis left behind and gets
picked up instead not good yes that one
on the left look particularly
disappointed
it looks like he's distracted by
something on the ground but he's just so
destroyed by what's going on right now
he can't keep his head up in fact I
would be surprised if every dog in this
movie has that exact same reaction just
constantly looking all over the place as
if they're always distracted but it's
not it's the pain of this one scene
that's ripping everybody up inside I
know I read the script it's in cram the
irony is as poorly as the animals are
trained in this movie that some of the
actors are trained even worse
take this kid for example he's as
invested as a wooden board who just
found out he's a wooden board okay how
about loser but what can you expect when
you're the son of Jeff Goldblum ah
kaprosuchus viscosity response uh Jeff
we haven't started recording yet I know
look he plays a scientist who's trying
to find a cure for dog allergies though
Bice cartoony dory it's where he was
trying to figure out how to blow up
anyone who came towards scrooge mcduck
shmoney bit ducktales woho lou is
approached by a secret-agent dog named
butch played by alec baldwin yeah humans
can get a little emotional you'll get
used to it ideal casting having alec
baldwin play a bitch
flag during review too easy a joke
replay last line critic has to say
something nice about the movie
man this is a real tough break for the
critic I hear you Frank but if you look
at the replay he clearly took too
obvious a stab at an easily unlikable
actor right you are Ken
oh and oh it looks like he's gonna try
and say something positive about the
film at least it's not Santa Paws and it
is good it works the review can continue
what fills in what he thinks is a cadet
about the catnapped it still makes no
sense to me agent this was your
predecessor agent one three six four aka
buddy we nicknamed in testicle chin try
to guess why Sam what's your 20
that's Sam he passed forwards the film
in fact all of us seem to do that a
little too much in this movie but I have
no excuse out of the house just lobby
request permission to pant heavily sir
granted hmm I hope that was just panting
don't play that again I don't need to
think about him touching his kibble in
bits all right screw it I'm just gonna
close my eyes I'm thinking more pleasant
things Yeah right you forced me to
combine the two actually I might started
a brand new fetish but Lola reveals he's
not an agent and Butch tells fox mccloud
his disappointment you promised me a
professional what do I get a pup there's
no time butch that puppy stays end of
discussion
and if you could tell slippy to save his
own warden ass every once in a while
that'd be super we then cut to our main
villain of the film mr. tinkles voiced
by Sean Hayes this is the best character
in the movie not because he's written
the best or perform the best but because
most of the time he's completely
animated allowing more control over the
character so I get open to world
domination pamphlets to page three I
will show you I want you to say yeah why
because I hate you with all the others
it's clear they're just waving treats in
front of them so they always look
unfocused and it's distracting as hell
but this character looks like he's
always in the moment because he
anime in that way at what point did you
forget the effect why wasn't this an
anime of film with all the CG used and
is it actually would have been a pretty
good CGI film with fewer limitations
instead we just have uninvested animals
looking like uninvested animals just
with little talking mouths put over them
why would anybody watch anything with a
character they know wasn't really in the
moment
hey nostalgia critic what were you look
left look right look up this confuses me
thank you
wait why'd you have me do that no reason
okay so the dogs tell Liu the back story
of their war between the cats he forced
them to build pyramids monuments
dogs being man's best friend rose up you
know do we really need a reason for cats
and dogs to hate each other we kind of
just get it
everybody knows what'll happen if that
wasn't the case dogs and cats living
together mass hysteria and the people
just forgot well you have to remember
they're very primitive species
heck they can't even take responsibility
for their own heart guilty well I'll
give him this for a film of this stature
that was a long time to wait for their
inevitable fart joke was that like 20
minutes in fart joke ears that's like an
eternity so-called boom once again tests
out his allergy cure oh no it's uh
turning me into the fly help me help me
even though it's not finished yet -
ninja cats try to sneak in to get the
formula
you know I don't know if this movie
understands when to use its cartoon
sound effects particularly the i i a
random cartoon sounds don't suddenly
equal comic gold they need to match the
mood and pacing for example this world
Heil everybody this doesn't oh go back
to acme looniversity until you pass your
exams all I did was give you dated 80s
comedy I don't know in fact this was the
first film to actually parody The Matrix
oh wait no it wasn't it was 157,000 but
it still feels really fresh right oh I
owe seven funny you're racist
easy you breathe the can't escape but
butch explains the seriousness of the
situation did you see when I had them
going with a right and left or right 11
then you got cocky you think this is a
game you think this is fun this isn't
about code names little boys or making
friends chicks think these are goofy
times or wacky antics
this is cats and dogs we only use our
III sound effect as a last resort I know
it may look like we're excitable animals
with a bit of string being waved over us
but this is deadly serious hey nostalgia
critic why are you doing that but I just
want to bet at it well why well what is
the purpose of this I do not understand
so I need who are you
you
hey guys 1c Nastasha Craig videos a week
early will now get Ken on vessel calm
the mustache correct schedule is still
exactly the same except now you can see
him a week early $3 a month
and on top of that you get access to a
lot of other vessel extra features you
can cancel anytime if you're not
interested things stay exactly the same
so go get a sneak peek when you get
comes across a dog named ivy played by
susan sarandon who seems familiar with
their undercover operation glad I'm not
the only one excited by the chicken I'm
sorry but I think you got to leave my
orders are clear I am cornered my weird
floating chicken alien legs question
that okay the almost perverted imagery
in this film is almost making me
uncomfortable okay now it's making me
uncomfortable I don't like this our way
to cut four secret lives of pets could
you do that again but it looks like the
boys and getting enough time with his
busy father because we're 40 minutes in
I guess we can start using that cliche
he's building a bomb dog allergies my
ass you're gonna see his name at an Isis
auction very soon I can assure you and
if you go to Isis auctions key give me
your name I just want to make a few
calls but it's okay because Luke eats
some company and how the bitch do you
get caught in a soccer net no seriously
that's not just stupid that's baby-proof
the stairs moronic
you'll replace my father now but butch
doesn't like everyone getting
sentimental with Lou and tells them to
back off you're barking up the wrong
tree
I'm gonna say this nice just once stay
away from the kid
Wow not since I put two dot eyes on a
stick figure I drew in first grade have
I seen such dead emotionless eyes
staring back at me this is one of the
few times there's no music in the movie
either every other second there's an
annoying dude did you did your duty but
here this close up is so intense they
actually leave the music off like they
know the drama of this scene you will
believe a dog can have no idea what he's
supposed to be looking at sorry a
close-up of eyes doesn't automatically
equal high drama
hey nostalgia critic thank you what
what are you doing that was you cannot
comprehend Oh women you try to make that
sound like something that was nothing
make America great again whoa
the mother comes across a stray cat and
brings him home only to discover it's
another spy I'm onto you kitty and
you're in big trouble
I think not baby puppy look up code for
human quick BAM
oh my butt all right break it up break
it up yeah knock it off dogs I don't own
why did that anger me they have a big
battle trying to fight off the cat but
the mother comes home has conveyed by
that keyhole shot very essential but
Gogol um accidentally knocks the cat out
with the door what does any of that have
to do with dog allergies unless you're
trying to contact Gozer to get her a
sample I don't see why you would need
all that I will tell you nothing
so the kid is captured or dog sure it
seems so stupid the other way around
and Luke gets to spend more time with
his boy Oh
how do you wish funny go on you a tummy
let's hear you know this kid is so
generic with his bland acting
non-threatening catchphrases at IKEA
bedroom display that I'm actually
starting to wonder if he's an animated
character he never seems real he always
feels half human half artificial a
Hogarth Joel Osment if he will yeah I
can remember all the times as a boy I
cheerfully shouted belly roll
though to be fair there any like the
ones before it might be warranted but
they stumble downstairs where Goldblum
seems to be lacing all his nuclear
explosives with food coloring
by God is every single one of Jeff
Goldblum's us he packaged them up look
there's an up from Jurassic Park there's
an off from powder and there's an O from
his biography uh-uh what daddy's very
angry when he discovers his work is
destroyed my rainbow fruit flavors now
no one will be able to try trout
strawberry what we get a dog us mutt see
not Oh what a sorry sight we have here
yeah it's not looking too good for
critic look at the two of them it's like
a small Chihuahua and a tiny miniature
football sized pool
yipping a teacher I'd say the critics
definitely the poodle as it turns out
that somehow created the cure for dog
allergies
aha I can finally partake in my dog
sniffing fetish no longer will this will
be an unfunny recycling of David
Letterman's stupid pet tricks but grumpy
cats sex change disguises himself as his
comatose master they send a fake
pamphlet saying the kid won a contest to
lure them to the factory your way versus
Chad I don't remember you entering any
contest though can we go please please
Jimmy go maybe he's an animatronic like
the ones that almost look real but just
make you uncomfortable
I can't smack them out and hold them
hostage to get the dog's attention
yeah I'll recognize these goons uh
listen uh if you're all kinda just just
take the bomb I've spent years
perfecting it change the battlefield
change the world so the dogs take a pod
that's so fast it knocks their heads
back except when it doesn't maybe that's
just a weird dog tick as they apparently
travel to the center of the earth where
their headquarters are okay this might
sound kind of silly but cats and dogs is
really losing me on its credibility it's
going off the rails even for this movie
I mean how gullible do they think we are
paying us all to critic
okay I'm not falling for another one
your trailer play fetch do I
all right wait wait no no you can't walk
away that easily I want some answers she
doing
oh my god I need to go our weekends the
world council voted to sacrifice the
Brody family when the dogs decide not to
save the family Wow dogs are kind of
dicks we find out why butch is so cold
to protect them we work for them so when
they go off to college they can W with
some old lady who can't throw a ball
without so much as breaking our hip is
that what happened to you no it's just a
completely random thing I said of course
it happened to me eventually though the
two of them decided to take on the cats
themselves as the family tries to stay
calm don't be scared Scotty
everything is gonna be okay Oh spirit
it's all right to be scared natural I'll
be okay oh really I'm okay uh I know
this is for a joke and all but I don't
care how old I am
I'd be pissing my pants seven colors of
fear this happened to me kid it's like
Pinocchio one day he'll be a real boy
but definitely not missing oh but I've
nothing to hide
maybe he's CG you know they're making
wonderful advances and not making CG Tom
Hanks look like a pedophile every human
in the world will be allergic to dogs
the cats it looks like have devised a
reversal formula that can make everybody
allergic to dogs it takes years to
create I'm sure it just takes seconds to
reverse and they plan to give it to mice
to spread all over the world mice
none of my mom you were right not to
laugh at that part let's bring out the
more appropriate side Oh Oh much better
they stopped the mice from leaving but
mr. tinkles lights the room on fire with
a family inside don't be scared son
I'm not scared I'm not even here I'm
hand-drawn and every single frame of
film remember so the dogs save the
family and fourth the cats plan but it
looks like Lou is still inside and well
Lou blue is it truly to rule out hand
puppet like Yoda but Lou is pulled out
by butch not entirely sure how he made
it through this but it looks like he
might not have pulled through whoa oh
man that's a that's just a shame that
sound of three dogs this week let's just
get a cat of course he survives as all
the mice are read their rights and
placed under arrest right to remain
silent than you so you can we'll make
out like God kind of a random time to
say that I'm sure there's a lot of other
scenes that deserve the saying of my god
my god so Lou please fetch with his
family because after discovering dogs
and cats are intelligent beyond measure
that's what I would want to do with them
as mr. tinkles is given to his owners
maid who does nothing but dress him up
with her sisters
you've been little spoon
if you feel like you're going totally
insane right now don't worry the films
actually been doing that to you for a
while
you're just only now noticing in fact
the credits are rolling right now but
because this movie is driven you so
bonkers this is all you can see it
succeeded in bringing on a complete
mental breakdown thus you can check
yourself into the cats and dogs mental
ward at your local mental health
trust me they all have them so what the
hell can I say about cats and dogs it's
from the same director of son of the
mask that explains a lot doesn't it well
it's nowhere near as bad as that film
you do see it's paw prints all over it
The awkward comedy mixed with confused
Direction combined with pointless sounds
and inconsistent effects it's not a good
flick which is a shame because it is
kind of a funny idea with funny
possibilities but as cat or dog vomit
goes this isn't one I'm looking forward
to cleaning up anytime soon so thank you
all for watching and tune in next time
when I take a look at dead a nostalgia
critic negative review I really hate
this movie it makes me want to shake my
head and anger so run away from it as
fast as you can I just want to swat at
every person who likes Deadpool what the
hell have you done
my wife recorded you for clipping
everybody's gonna click on a negative
review of Deadpool but I like to pull
tell the comments that this is fact and
I'm gonna report you you can kiss your
channel goodbye go ahead we just called
fox and told them that all your videos
have Deadpool in them your channel will
be gone before you can even make the
report all they have to do is watch the
video - no I'm not doing god dammit
you
ah
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week I am doing one
that everybody tells me is just a
phenomenal one it's called heifer
international their mission is to end
hunger and poverty while caring for the
earth and for 70 years they provided
livestock and environmentally sound
agricultural training to improve the
lives of those who struggle daily for
reliable sources of food and income but
the way they go about it is very unique
they link communities and help bring
sustainable agriculture and commerce to
areas with the long history of poverty
their animals provide partners with food
and reliable income as agricultural
products such as milk eggs honey can be
traded or sold at the market and as you
imagine when many families gain this new
sustainable income it brings new
opportunities for building schools
forming communities savings and even
funding small businesses you can check
out their YouTube channel or their
website to see all the good they're
spreading and see how you can not only
stop a family from going hungry but also
grow their community into one that will
never have to worry about that again
check out the link and see all the
phenomenal work that they're doing
you